for the marlins they hand the ball to
pablo lopez it'll be his 19th start of
the season of course last time he faced
the braves just one pitch figures to go
a little deeper
today open has been a bit taxed of late
yeah there have been a few days over the
course of the
last four or five where it's been four
innings from one pitcher
out of the bullpen but a good start for
pablo he gets his first strikeout this
afternoon and there's one away
freeman two for four yesterday with a
home run has had a big
series against the marlins three for
seven couple of home runs
oh two pitchers swinging a miss he got
him on a change up
so six pitches in back-to-back case for
pablo lopez
forget the history against the braves
we're living in the present
ozzy albies in this series two hits and
nine at bats has an rbi double
and pablo gets the strikeout wasn't
immaculate but it was still pretty good
strikes out the side
in the first sad news yesterday of
ronald acuna junior's season-ending
injury jazz chisholm junior wearing the
yellow batting gloves to honor his buddy
ronald lacuna jr today change-up tipped
into the glove of kevin smith a first
inning opportunity for the marlins with
jesus aguilar at the plate
first couple of free passes issued by
anderson
his 01 pitch coming and aguilar sends
one out to left field that's deep
that is
ball of the day actually put in play by
either side
and it's a three-run shot yeah partner
wasn't in play for a long time
that they got out of here in about two
seconds over that left field wall
second home run of the season for
aguilar here at lone depot park starting
to find that home run stroke
and now sanchez out toward left center
field the braves had
garcia nearly in the corner and that one
falls in for a knock
now rojas still just won out
and miggy finds a hole on the right side
sanchez will stop at second and the
marlins are
really taking advantage of anderson here
in this first inning
and he chased another one high fastballs
take care of pablo lopez but a three run
homer by
jesus aguilar gives miami an early lead
saw the cutter you saw the curve ball
first the fourth seamer in the chain
jump
now he is four for four today he has
struck out
every brave to this point down the last
three on the changeup
it's how locked in he is right now
pablo's got a 395 era and nine starts
one two swing and a miss
how about that five batters in five
strikeouts for lopez
oh two to swanson swing and a miss six
up six down all k's for pablo lopez
two and two and a called strike three
that's the marlins
record right there seven
in a row to start the ball game for
pablo lopez now that change has been so
effective that hitters are starting to
guess already
0-2 on kevin smith here's the pitch
swing and a miss
and pablo lopez has tied a major league
record
eight consecutive strikeouts to start a
ball game
absolutely dialed in this afternoon you
give him a lead i mean he's just gone on
the attack
since the minute this game started his
tempo has been outstanding his
pitch execution
right on point
one ball two strikes and here it comes
cold strike three major league record
pablo lopez nine strikeouts in a row to
start the day
sanchez at third rojas at first one two
on the way to sandy leone and that's a
ground ball right side
albies gets to it gets it to first and
an rbi ground out makes it four nothing
this guy's playing catch at 92 and 88
looks smooth looks fluid it's
right where he wants it to be not that
one though as the braves have their
first hit
who better than freddie freeman to break
up the perfect game bid
that is his 14th double and there's the
start for atlanta
one on one out goes ozzy albee's batch
for the second time
sharply hitting through for a base hit
freeman's going to get the green light
cooper loads up here comes his throw it
is late
and as he moves up on the throw to
sandy leone ozzy all be 61 rbis in the
braves come
right back it's 4-1 even though i know
he struck out the first nine it felt
like
eight nothing the way this game was
going but
off the end of the bat into right center
field that's down for a hit the braves
are
back in the game it's four to two
what you do is you protect coop you
protect aguilar from
you know too many opportunities to not
only you know
avoid the double plays but i'm saying
sure
that's one way to get to the beginning
that is a hot shot past riley it'll get
all the way to the wall
marta comes in to score garrett cooper
cruises into second base and the marlins
get one back
on the double by coupe call 62 aguilar
61
alby's 61 but let's admit that cooper is
going to get the green light around
third here comes the throw from center
it's off the mark another rbi for jesus
aguilar and the marlins
answer back with two more and lead it
six to two
and a line drive caught by aussie albies
who timed his leap
perfectly showing the ups
it's a good job by aussie because it
looked like it was hit harder than it
was
chip and massive got in on him and ozzie
did a good job of waiting
to time that jump in he has struck out
he has
walked
and he unloads to left center deepest
part of the ballpark
and it is gone dansby swanson with a
two-out home run
number 14 for the brave shortstop
his great series continues that's his
fifth hit in miami and the braves are
down three now
that's down the right field line that'll
wake up a few
pooches in the ballpark it gets caught
under the wall sanchez on his way to
second but he is not gonna stop there
on his way to third with a two-out
triple
biggie hanging tough it'll be a
three-two pitch and it's off the club of
freeman
albie gets to it throw to first
[Applause]
miguel rojas with a hot shot to first
off the glove of
freeman four-game hitting streak will be
carried into the break for swanson he's
eight for 16 in that stretch
and dansby hits another one a country
mile he's got a two-homer game
might want to rethink this all-star
break thing
miami trying to finish off the first
half with a win and they will do
just that it's a marlins win
anthony bender gets the strikeout and it
ends the way that it starts
pablo lopez setting a major league
record nine
consecutive strikeouts to begin the ball
game